there is new video out this morning and
it shows another violent confrontation
on board a plane cell phone video
captures two passengers look at this
just punching each other out on a
Southwest Airlines flight right after it
landed in California Kris Van Cleave is
in Washington with the latest in a
series of violent incidents involving
air travel Chris good morning good
morning
this time the fight broke out as
passengers were getting off flight 2530
from Dallas Southwest says one passenger
was arrested another suffered minor
injuries this is just the latest in what
seems like a daily string now of
altercations and flat-out fisticuffs
this video captured by a passenger
onboard a Southwest flight shows anger
turning to violence two passengers trade
punches and wrestle with one another in
the seats Sunday shortly after landing
at Burbank Airport in Los Angeles you
can see a Southwest flight attendant
attempting to break up the fistfight but
she ends up getting caught in the melee
one of the passengers was eventually
arrested Michael Krause was on the
flight Southwest Airline I've never had
a problem with him and they did an
absolutely wonderful job and they're not
all bad there's no word on what caused
the fight but airlines have been
struggling to contain the tension
boiling over on planes and in airports
you did not have my permission to
videotape it why now you argue to me I
want I wandering away came to the
reservation over the weekend a man
trying to catch a United flight to San
Francisco from New Orleans says he was
prevented from boarding after recording
a dispute between him and a United
representative over a bag fee last week
it was Delta that looted a family from a
flight during a dispute over a seat
last april dr. David Dow was dragged off
his united flight when he refused to
give up his seat
later that month an American Airlines
flight attendant was grounded when he
confronted passengers over a baby
stroller do you do that to me and I'll
knock you Poinciana me and one airline
is even fighting with its pilots anger
at Spirit Airlines nearly turned into a
riot at Fort Lauderdale Airport
thousands of spirit customers have faced
canceled flights due to a work dispute
with the Airlines pilots now despite
what we just saw there the number of
unruly passengers is way down this year
only nine reported to the FAA through
early April but that number may tick up
now spirit want a restraining order
against the pilot Union yesterday but
the airline is bracing for dozens of
cancellations again today as it works to
get back to normal we should tell you
American United and Delta of all
apologized for the incidents in this
story Norah alright Chris thank you so
much